so yeah it was run into the gym get a
mat get into the bathroom get the mat on
the floor
towels down brace brace brace queen
elizabeth
ii's 10th great grandchild arrived in a
very very dramatic fashion
zara tindall the daughter of princess
anne and mark phillips
welcomed a baby boy on sunday with her
hubby
mike tyndall mike confirmed the news on
monday during an episode of his podcast
the good the bad and the rugby
a little baby boy arrived at my house
mike shares that his baby boy
arrived at 6 pm local time on sunday
night
weighing 8 pounds 4 ounces though he
says he and zara hadn't picked out a
name
a spokesperson for the couple later told
the telegraph that their child had been
named
lucas philip tindall the middle name in
honor of both
mike's father as well as zara's
grandfather prince philip
who recently returned to windsor castle
after an extended hospital stay
all sounds totally normal totally cute
right
well get this little lucas came so
fast that his parents didn't make it to
the hospital in time
and instead welcomed him to the world on
their
bathroom floor fortunately zara's friend
dolly
is she's actually more important than i
am at making sure that she's been at
every three of my
my children's births she was there and
recognized that we wouldn't have got to
hospital in time
so yeah it was run into the gym get a
mat get into the bathroom get the mat on
the floor
towels down brace brace brace luckily
the two midwives who were supposed to
attend the birth
arrived at the house just as the little
boy was coming out
the second midwife arrived just after
the head the head and
arrived as for the couple's two
daughters
seven-year-old mia and two-year-old lena
mike says they weren't around for the
big moment
fortunately zed i think she'd sort of
had
contractions through the night she
hadn't slept well the night before so
we had someone take the kids for the day
he added that the girls are quote
over the moon to have a baby bro and the
pro-rugby player went
on to praise his wife as every man
will say that she was a warrior as
always they always are
we can never we can never judge for what
we know in terms of what they have to go
through with childbirth so
no she was she was back up uh we went
for a walk this morning
and he said that you are done having
kiddos
like real done i literally was like yep
snip
sniff limit i got a boy i got my boy i'm
out i'm out of here